good morning Hank it's Wednesday my
house gets so nice
No right this visit my house this is a
hotel room in the great city of Chicago
Illinois where I am with David Levithan
because we are on tour for Will Grayson
Will Grayson schmancy hotel is schmancy
so there's this amazing tongue with the
nerdfighter joint called fu nerdfighters
linked in the doobly-doo
and in the last day a lot of tumblers of
tumblers tumblings tom balloons tumblers
tombliboos tombliboo x' a lot of
tombliboos have been uploading pictures
of themselves holding Will Grayson Will
Grayson but because of the mirroring of
digital images that used to make it so
hard for me to figure out how to point
to the doobly-doo it appears many of
these people are not uploading pictures
of themselves with a book called Will
Grayson Will Grayson but instead with a
book called nasi argh
lue nasi argh Lu which it believed the
accursed me would have been a great
title if we write a sequel it's gonna be
called nasi our blue nasi our glue so
last night was the first event of the
tour Hank it was great two things I have
to tell you first
there was a stormtrooper not a Nazi
stormtrooper a Star Wars stormtrooper
also there were a lot of people wearing
this which is odd because it's hard to
focus on what you're saying when there's
a pedophilic pizza loving version of
yourself staring back at you oh oh and
check this out don'tdon't ah yeah it's
pretty awesome French the llama oh and
Africa love nothing here's David and me
outside of French cheese here we are we
are at Frenchy's
only funny if you've read the book so
but speaking of books your video on
Monday which by the way I love maybe
think about the Google ization of
information in the contemporary world
I've long thought that Google is
technically making us stupider as
individuals because the internal hard
drive inside of our heads is not as
needed anymore because we have these
massive external hard drives that Google
can index like for instance when I was a
kid I knew the phone numbers of all my
friends don't be me that's not fair I
had friends imaginary friends can have
imaginary phone numbers okay geez but
anyway I knew dozens of imaginary phone
numbers now I know like for phone
numbers because I have this amazing
external hard drive that stores all the
phone numbers I want and I've been
thinking lately Hank that one of the
things long-form narratives like novels
do is they help us to arrange lots of
information into a story right because
it's much easier to remember things in a
narrative than it is to remember random
dislocated facts but now that we have
these external hard drives that are so
good at remembering random facts we no
longer need to organize information
narrative ly in order to trick our
crappy hard drives into remembering it
and Hank I worried that as we spend more
time on the Internet by the way internet
I'm not trying to hurt your feelings
here you know I love you I don't don't
get mad at me I I know you're listening
you're always listening I worry that we
will lose our interest in and think
we're losing our need for those
long-form narratives that have for so
long been a huge part of what it means
to be a person now I think that worries
me partly because my job is writing
those long-form narratives but it also
worries me for other reasons but
nerdfighters I'm interested to know if
you find it harder to read books these
days I know that sometimes I do
obviously I love books but sometimes
even when I'm enjoying a book I find
myself putting it down to look at the
flashy flashy lights of the internet so
nerdfighters again I hope you like Will
Grayson Will Grayson helps you galata
you on tour and Hank I will see you on
Friday